[Music]
our parents used to have uh diesel
mercedes which sounds really like
hoity-toity but it was an older car one
day it was home and my parents weren't
the car was home we were all taking
turns blocking each other right in the
trunk and we did like every permutation
it was just you and then
just me and you and then me and me oh
god you have a better memory than me the
final permutation was just you and
damian apparently christian left and he
went back inside to watch cartoons i
think i went back inside and i fell
asleep so meanwhile while he's dreaming
my older brother damian and i are in an
it was it felt like a nightmare it was
the first time i thought i was going to
doc kind of had to like mentally prepare
myself for dying then i woke up in a
panic and i remember this i still
remember very clearly i was probably
five years old and i panicked and i ran
outside and i opened the latch and i
still remember you and damien
white as ghosts and panting for air yeah
i i saved your life well ha ha
technically i guess
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
uh welcome to life is short i'm your
host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is my life-saving
brother your hero yeah what a hero the
only reason obviously you saved my life
is because you put it in jeopardy uh i
did and i'm sorry i don't know if i've
ever formally apologized to that
actually well you know what's funny i
remember when the trunk opened seeing
you there and i don't know to this day
if i've ever had this strong a mix of
gratitude and anger at the same time oh
really i only sense gratitude yeah
well maybe i maybe the gratitude
overwhelmed the anger if you
legitimately thought that you were maybe
going to die yeah the anger would have
come much later oh my god even if your
worst enemy saved your life you'd be
like oh all is forgiven you know it's a
little scary that i did that in the
first place
i think about that sometimes and i think
yeah was i a little like joshua i
remember the movie josh yeah or like a
little evil like the kid from the
shining a little bit not that he was
evil he just heard things right but
here's where he was plagued by his own
powers whenever i get worried about my
having been an evil child i
feel better when i remember that moment
when i woke up and you panicked it's
crazy if you were evil you wouldn't
exactly it's crazy that i left and went
inside and fell asleep that's crazy when
i woke up i remember panicking and being
really scared and running out to save
you yeah like damien the omen wouldn't
be like oh i i'm trying to remember what
david
not damien our brother
you know it's crazy that our parents
named damian our brother
just a few months before the movie came
exactly it was like two months before
yeah it's bad timing yeah it's like it's
like a bad omen
but damian turned out great so yeah he's
not at all like damien with e and i
remember they were always quick to point
out that damian our older brother spells
it with an a and not an e like this
spawn of satan yes i think we've talked
about this before but you did save my
life a couple other times you saved me
from drowning once and you saved me from
you fell off a high i fell off changing
changing table and you cushioned my fall
anyway why are we talking about our own
relatively tame
not really near death experiences
because these are the closest we've had
to near-death experiences but our guest
today yeah has legitimately had a
near-death experience like a dramatic
one yeah where his where he had a 20
chance of surviving our guest today is
kevin smith he's very much alive and
still as creatively virile and potent as
ever
he is
an incredible writer director
somebody i've worked with many times
he's been a huge part of my
professional life and a very enjoyable
part of my personal life
does that sound like we're dating yeah
it sounds like you did date and now
you're friends again yeah we we we um
put the pieces back together and salvage
a friendship um no we never dated but we
uh
but i really i really like kevin kevin's
a friend of mine and um somebody who
i've always
admired professionally and uh feel very
fortunate to have gotten to work with
many times on which movies uh so we we
met on die hard four on on live free or
die hard kevin came in to play the
hacker and then kevin put me in a couple
other movies starting with we did zach
and mary make a porno then we did a
movie called tusk and uh in kevin's
movie zach and miri make a porno
with seth rogen i played i had a small
part as a gay porn star
ten years later kevin is making this
movie jane's silent bob reboot which
you'll hear us talking about and kevin
asked me to essentially play that
character but as a lawyer so we talk
about the challenges and why it didn't
necessarily work
just to give you a little bit of context
for that character and he uh he was this
very aggressive based on somebody that i
actually knew the character's name was
brandon st randy and you'll hear us
talking about him and he kind of talked
like this oh my god it's funny that you
can't do the voice without doing the
face oh really
crazy well it was an interesting
character and i'm not sure if we talk
about this uh
before i did the movie to prepare for
the character which sounds like [ __ ]
i watched gay porn and i noticed that
the guys in that
the 50k points that i'd seen the guys
were like really butch you know in those
movies they're very like what's up bro
and then they then they start hooking up
were they like do they have that energy
on set when you went to visit and
try out a couple moves uh some of them
did um but anyway that's the character
right before we recorded this interview
i did kevin's podcast which which i had
never done smodcast it's called yeah
kevin lives in a beautiful home up in
the hollywood hills and uh he's got this
great big office that's just filled with
toys from his movies and hockey jerseys
which he wears and
it's this great little podcast setup and
there's an ashtray that is just lined
with pre-rolled joints
and it's so inviting to and he smokes
throughout the interview
but you weren't stoned for this
interview no so the next day when i went
back i was determined not to be stoned
tusk is a movie that if you haven't seen
it it's very polarizing i think where
people either really love it or are like
horrified by it to the point where
they're like upset with you as a person
yeah probably made it i still think
people are confused by that happened on
instagram recently somebody tagged me in
this thing and they were like
justin what were you thinking that some
thing like that like what the [ __ ] um
and you were like i do anything kevin
smith basically yeah basically
but i remember mom calling after that
movie i think she left the theater to
make this phone call she said i don't
ever want you working with that man
again he's psychotic there's something
wrong with him he's deranged she's
arranged yeah she said something like
that like you said it's polarizing we
went to the uh we were at the premiere
of it at toronto film festival a few
years oh my god and it was
on my birthday actually oh that's right
it was a midnight screening and people
there were for the most part huge kevin
smith fans to the point where they were
like there was this energy in the air it
was like this these rabbits
a lot of whom had uh walrus masks on and
costumes and all this they gave they
handed out those walrus man those some
people had really like elaborated
elaborate yeah and oh and and they were
doing this uh cross promotion remember
that with um a weed company
it was almost like they knew it was
gonna be a stoner culty movie before it
ever came out and so they they branded
these they created these two strains of
weed one was like it's sativa and one
was indica and so people were and they
were hand i think they were
handing those out they were and i smoked
like one hit of this weed he was like oh
there's the thing that everyone's doing
is part of the experience
i got so stoned from it
as it was i was got a little two stone
from the one head and i was looking
around and all these crazy fans with the
walrus
i was a little uncomfortable to begin
with and then kevin came out to speak to
introduce the film
his introduction at midnight to this
film
was a good 35 minutes i think it was
maybe longer than or more yeah but it
felt like
nine hours yeah it felt like i was
trapped there it felt like i was in
prison and i was being tortured
that sounds awful
because kevin is brilliant he's
incredible as you'll hear about here
he's a brilliant speaker yeah but when
you're really stoned and it's midnight
on your birthday and there's people
wearing walrus masks all around you
you don't want to hear kevin smith talk
for 35 minutes and then at the end to
say like so stick around afterwards for
a q a yeah
yeah this was special for me because
i've i've been a fan of kevin since i
was a kid since i was i think a freshman
in high school when
you know clerks and mall rats came out
and then chasing amy yeah
that was all high school yeah yeah
that's what i was discovering it was
like a really indelible part of my high
school experience i think yeah we love
those movies totally i wasn't a comic
book nerd per se but his very like wordy
irreverent dialogue was something that i
really gravitated towards yeah high
school it felt like it broke the rules
of of movie making as i had known it i
will forever be grateful to kevin for
that and and for putting me in
a tusk i mean tusk was a really
important movie for me as was zach and
mira like kevin's been a part of a lot
of like very important professional
moments in my life so
and he's one of the original podcasters
i mean like he he was like the first guy
one of the first to start doing this to
bring it into the mainstream so you owe
him
man
you owe him like i owe you for saving my
life yes
i also like he's the one that got me
into wearing uh hockey jerseys every day
and posing with my thumbs up uh all
right so up next it's just it's ironic
that we've spoken so long about kevin
yeah after being like he talked too much
before we went on too long uh so here's
justin's chat with kevin smith life
could be a dream sweetheart
indochino okay indochino makes suits and
shirts to your exact measurements for an
unparalleled fit the fit is not does not
have any other parallels that's what
unparalleled means but it's true they
take your exact measurements now
what if the shirt shrinks or your body
type changes what if you're like
christian bale i thought you're going to
say me
i was about to be really offended by
that oh what if you're like christian
long or bale
then you just keep getting uh your
measurements retaken or submit your
measurements it's that easy and you're
gonna love it you're gonna love the huge
selection and if you're like justin and
you love personalizing your shirts
including your lapel oh yeah lining the
pockets buttons justin personalizes all
everything is monogrammed jl everywhere
my underwear all monitors you can write
your own monogram on on the clothes i'm
still enjoying my plaid shirt that i got
oh man it fits fits like a glove as jim
carrey once said like a glove
remember that yeah that's a terrible
terrible jim carrey yeah they're great
they're suits yeah fit better than
generic off the rack suits it'd be great
to get a suit yeah uh this week our
listeners can get any premium indochino
suit for just 369
at indochino.com with code long at
checkout l-o-n-g
plus shipping is um it's quite cheap but
how much is it's like it's fue oh it's
zero dollars zero dollars and zero cents
indochino.com promo code long for any
premium suit for just 369
and free shipping it's a great deal
[Music]
here we are i'm in kevin's
uh
this is an office
it's strange to call this an office
because i remember my dad has an office
my dad's a philosophy professor and his
is just like old books everywhere and
this i'm looking at
posters and trinkets and toys from all
kevin's world do you remember
tusk
when you're like it's like a museum
that's what this is it's a museum that's
totally that's what it is and it's
[ __ ] cool and there's a little pont
he's got a podcasting outfit here i will
be nervously looking away from you for
the next hour or so don't make offense
to it the reason he tell him why the
reason why is because um
we've been talking for the last uh hour
what time is an hour and
20 minutes
there were a few points where i was like
god damn this is fun this is good and
like we're getting great i'm getting
podcasting gold he's opening up and he's
talking we're talking about
god and the afterlife and neil patrick
harris and and everything in between and
i'm like this is it we're flying like
i'm playing with lebron you know i'm
playing one-on-one and i'm kind of like
you know it's not that it's a
competition but like that's not
embarrassing
oh my god you're right there yeah
and uh
we weren't rolling and what i did is i
pressed the button
and
it
i guess either the the sd card is
completely full
um or
for some reason the machine just like
locked up but we normally when i record
i'm constantly looking over to make sure
the red light is on well we were so
deeply engaged i know [ __ ] that i did
not look over to the red light i thank
god i looked but about an hour and
changing i was like let me just make
sure i also this is the first time i
keep doing this joke like
as things if the conversation's kind of
like heating up and going well and i
always end up saying like as a joke i
say uh we should start recording
you know let's let's should we record
and it's the first time i didn't do that
and i know i wish because i was like i
can't do that in every episode
i can't do this
i would actually do the work
god damn it so now i'm like [ __ ] but the
stoners will understand this uh when
you're really stoned and you've ordered
food
your stomach's making noises and you're
like [ __ ]
and you realize you hadn't pressed send
and it's been like an hour you
know and now i feel like i'm just going
to keep referencing things that we had
been talking about it's going to be ways
to go forward and if the old stuff comes
up it comes out that's good here here
look let's do let's housekeeping yeah
you help me out here yeah we came here
from an episode of smodcast
which we recorded yesterday in this very
same room right here in this space but
uh so for those who followed us over
welcome to the second part of our
conversation
if you didn't hear the first part of
this conversation it's not going to be
necessary to listen but
but go listen to craig yes but i did
promise that if we come over here i
would talk about what justin did in jay
and sam bob reboot yeah so when you
called me to do that that wasn't easy we
talked about that it was an easy
decision he jumped in now here's the
thing i'm playing the character that i
played in in kevin's movies spoilers
spoilers yes he's absolutely right um i
when i wrote jane zombob reboot i love
the character
brandon st randy the justin blade and
zacky mary megaporno um so much so that
like i always wanted to just decide
brandon st randy movie my brother is gay
as the days long he's been married to
his husband jerry since i made clerks
the year of clerks came out oh wow
before they got [ __ ] gay married long
before it was cool yeah anybody was like
you're allowed to they were like yeah
[ __ ] you yeah they got married in
unitarian church wow and so they've been
married and you know for
25 years which 25 years in the gay
community is a long ass [ __ ] time in
any community yeah but my brother he
loved brandon st randall oh that's
zach and mary he's like that he's going
bro
uh i watched gay porn not prosef yes
bro period
um he nailed it i always loved that
character i was like i'm bringing that
[ __ ] character people have been very
complimentary about that that's so nice
to hear oh online people refer to it as
one of the greatest cameos of all time
because it is just like you drop into
the movie
it's [ __ ] hysteric everything you say
is [ __ ] stereotypical it was a
drought joy and it was also a character
that i kind of
knew a little bit before my
very close friend john togo uh
used to work at a restaurant called the
viceroy in chelsea and he was the only
straight waiter
and and all the rest of the staff the
the
other waiters took him under their wings
you know
and really looked out for him if he ever
got like aggressively hit on they would
be like
you know leave her alone she's not in
the club you know they would make sure
that he was protected and he told me
some
great stories about the stories that
they would share with one another after
like a weekend of going out and hooking
up with people and stuff and um that's
there's one story i remember
that's where you get the one line well
that's where i got the one line and he's
and he said he overheard one of those
guys saying to his partner in a flirty
way he goes you better shut your mouth
or i'm gonna kiss it i always thought it
was the funniest [ __ ] line you better
shut your your mouth and i'm going to
kiss it in like a flirtatious way but
it's almost at a hospital hostile yeah
like you don't know
you're going to get it
you're going to get it in the mouth
and you uh allowed me to you the
original line when i was doing that
character was um i was in poo punchers
one two
and then there was one line i don't know
if the script was like i was in two
punches one two three four
not five you know he made him say he
wasn't in five and he returned for six
like he had a beef with the production
company but
that really made me laugh but you that
one of the reasons i came up with
instead you were like you [ __ ]
well this is gonna sound really arrogant
but one of the reasons i love working
with you is that you we have very
similar sense of humor i mean i it's why
i like your movies i just we
that's why we're friends i just so you
kind of give me space
and and we have i get to do these great
scripts of yours but and we were talking
about this yesterday
it's the best place to improvise from
when you already have it's it's almost
like you have that confidence of knowing
that like i have it we've done it and
the script is funny we got it
it's the best place to like kind of go
off and and you can't ask for a better
partner than seth rogen i mean jesus
that was watching you too it was just my
favorite day i wasn't said ever it was
just it was mine it's hysterical so you
could uh crying my face hurt
it was so fun even though i was like
sick as a dog but it was [ __ ] fun and
i don't know if i told you this but uh
brandon ralph who played bobby he at one
point you know i i
you were letting us go for so long at
one point when you're pl doing a scene
with with someone that you're
romantically
with
there's a chance that it'll eventually
get to like a show of affection and so
and as we're improvising this stuff like
we we get we're in a fight and then we
make up and okay and and i went up and i
went he's so tall that i like went up to
kiss him you know i had to go on my
tiptoes and i'll never forget the look
on his face as i approached because
brandon was like you know it's an
improvised moment i would go to kiss him
like we've made up i'm going to kiss him
that's what you do with your lover
and i could see
i registered like a moment of panic in
his face as i was approaching like he's
not really gonna and he kind of tried to
move his head aside and i followed his
mouth with my man i just planted one and
um afterwards i go i said uh but i was
so sick i i went up to him and i said um
brian i'm so sorry um about that you
know about the the kiss and he goes oh
no no and he was kind of thrown but like
a good sport about it and he was like
no look i mean that's the part right
we're playing
that's i said no no no it's not that i
kissed you is that because i'm sick
i don't want you to get sick i don't
know what you do you know he goes you
know he got really like super manly
confident he was like oh no no i
i never get sick i'm like you know he
came short of saying like i'm the man of
steel like i don't my immune system is
like incredible and and years late
couple years later i ran into his him
and his wife and um
the wife said oh my god you know brandon
came home and he got he was sicker than
i've ever seen him
and i i had a moment of like weird
uh i i was like weird pride that i've
gotten superman
[Music]
i was just crying you did something that
lex couldn't totally totally i cracked
him but that man that [ __ ] so we were
talking about um that yesterday and
about the reboot so in reboot you come
back i i've written
uh the part of this part of this lawyer
and i didn't like write it's brandon
saint randy but in the script at one
point it said he sounds an awful lot
like vance it's pretty clear knowing
that justin was going to play the part
and couldn't [ __ ] wait to shoot that
scene we shot the scene it was great
[ __ ] fun and the scene is wonderful
in the movie but
it's very expositional you gave me a lot
of exposition
and i wound up cutting it right to the
script yeah yeah pretty much like it's
it is a lot of exposition it's what sets
the story in motion and he justin like
was able to ring comedy out of what he
could
with the stuff where it's like he has to
[ __ ] deliver information yeah um and
it was kind of like look somebody's
going to deliver this information
the best person to do it i was flat
that's that's flattering brandon randy
he'll make it entertaining well that's
fl that's the ultimate that's very
flattering because i it was that it was
just informational like this we need
this and the audience to know this stuff
together it wasn't like the fun stuff
that zach and mary was um but but i i
love doing that character so much that
just even doing like heavy legal
expeditions like jargon was still
that guy was still fun people people but
it was the best um but
as i didn't direct them properly
we have a bunch of photos that we can't
use and this is why this is interesting
so when we made zack and mary megaporno
uh justin is playing brandon st randy
who tells
uh zach
who he is
i'm a male gay porn star
and so everything he says after that
like is earned and makes sense because
we know what he does for a living and
why he's saying these outrageous [ __ ]
things right in jay and zombob reboot
there was never this moment of
i'm a lawyer i used to be a gay male
porn star interesting i wondered that
now i'm i'm this we never had that we
never said that it was never in the
script because
the guy who wrote the script knows that
brandon randy is a male gay porn star
and knows the guy playing him knows that
so he's like well i don't have to
that's interesting so then we have a
bunch of footage of justin ad living
brilliantly in character
but when you cut it into the movie it's
like what the [ __ ] it it just rang as
like
why
why did you decide to make the lawyer
not only gay but like but a [ __ ] hungry
gay cartoon totally pervy and i was like
well wait a second but yeah but he was
this and zach and mir and that's when it
occurred to me like yes but in zack and
mary he was at the movie was called
zagamer megaporno he was a character who
was like i am legitimately in porn yeah
and a gay male porn star so everything
he talks about and all the sexual stuff
and the flirtation
is makes sense because you're like
you've been presented with that
character in this movie all you're
presented with is a guy who winds up
being a lawyer
and for no good reason he's flirting
with joe manchinella trying to [ __ ]
everybody
especially you can't put that character
in joe manginello in a room together and
not have him like go after him it was i
had people come up to me like the guy
who recorded the sound
i was like i've been in this business 20
years i've never seen anyone that good
in my life they were [ __ ] brilliant i
was i was so proud
to bring justin to work and unpack him
because it was like this is my this is
my racing oh man because like i knew
we were gonna get our work done and i
knew everyone was gonna get a [ __ ]
show
so they were all like there were so many
people that were blown away
by like how funny and original and
[ __ ] creative justin was and like oh
my god they're like that's gonna be an
amazing scene and i too was just like
it's [ __ ] interesting and it wasn't
until i cut together the first scene
that i was like
we're missing a piece of information and
it wouldn't even help to be like let's
go back and add a line about how he used
to be right because suddenly they're
like why does that allow you to do all
this as well right exactly exactly and
then there was a piece that was like it
was just you know zach and mary was 2007
well that was going to say it may be
blessing in disguise because can you
even do that anymore the thing it said
suddenly that character was very
aggressive and but within within that
movie makes utter sense absolutely and i
know people there's a day and age where
it's like
you know you get in trouble for like you
know you're casting a guy playing gay
character he's not really getting ready
that's very true in fact i just did an
interview for um
yeah
it was for not the advocate but a gay
publication
and the interviewer was very uh
complimentary about zach and mary
and i but i brought up
i brought up zacky mary i said
can you do that now and he said i don't
you know we've talked about it we had a
nice conversation about it but
i don't know that that you can i don't
think you can i don't know i don't know
what the rules are when it comes to that
uh i mean well i well it becomes two
questions i don't know if you could do
it anymore right i don't know if you
could do it at all at all that's
interesting about
what is now offensive and what what are
the different rules and some of it is
like the motivation for it is
completely like long overdue
um but it does you start you then have
to rewrite some of the comedy rules
which is like that's fine yeah i don't
understand like the people who are like
oh man you can't i can't do anything
right right
like
are you afraid of saying i mean you just
you talk for a living i yeah and you
have to self-edit constantly yeah like
work in real time and and you know you
just have to accept the fact that look
there's a bunch of things i say i go out
of my way not to offend people and in
doing so that will offend somebody well
sometimes you're just your general
sensibilities yeah and like people like
i
i put up uh you know [ __ ] there's all
this abortion chatter going on because
of alabama and georgia and you know
somebody put up uh is
two frames from dogma
in which jay and salam bob are outside
the abortion clinic and and uh
bethany had asked like are you guys
protesters and
they say [ __ ] no uh me and son bob are
pro-choice a woman's body's her own
[ __ ] business
and so you know i threw it up on my
instagram thing
and was just like
you know this this this moment brought
out it wasn't it wasn't even like yeah
yeah that moment when a movie you did 20
years ago
worthy yeah you know just kind of yeah
and so
there were some people that were like
well consider yourself unfollowed leave
your politics out of this but i'm like
bro
you know i said that 20 years ago right
and you're still a fan of mine yeah like
i didn't say that recently that's
something that was said in 1999 yeah and
presumably you saw that movie you never
at least know of its existence and also
like it's not like that was the movie
where i suddenly got less conservative
right and more liberal like no the
movies the first one begins with like
they've all got pre-marital sex like
they've all got drugs true like yeah
one's about catholicism but there's ass
[ __ ] jokes in it like how'd you make
it
how did you get through clerks
i mean jesus so you know it's clear i
don't go out there and force my politics
on people i'm you know i don't [ __ ]
sit around and talk about the president
[ __ ] like that because
if you see my this is the one area of my
life like you know most people like
david fincher makes a movie and then
david fincher don't go out and do like
19 podcasts and a live tour and always
come out after the building let me tell
you what happened bruce got in a fight
he lets the work speak for itself right
me i'm the other guy who's like let me
tell you how that happened and blah blah
blah but
when it comes to
to my politics that's where i let the
work speak for itself oh interesting i'm
just like
look
you've seen the movie yeah right yeah
you've listened to the podcast it's like
clearly
you have a perspective yeah and i don't
force it down people's throats going
whoever don't think my way is a [ __ ]
idiot but like
you don't know what's going to trigger
somebody that's [ __ ] that photo for
as many people that were like [ __ ]
yay yeah there were i would say a
quarter of that were people who were
angered by well and social media allows
you to
to just go with those whims it allows
you to just be taken by those
fits of outrage or jealousy or whatever
it is because you can just with a click
of a button and or a couple buttons you
can tell somebody that they suck or that
you don't like them or you can just stop
following somebody you can you can
disengage with a click of a button you
know what it is i think instead of
talking it through it's not only just i
was going to say this generation but i
don't think it's this generation it's
this modern world
we make things
um so
tailor-made the direct consumer
is all about
we got to get them where they live so
let's
create something where we could they can
just order something from a convenience
store somebody will drop it off to them
they don't want to leave their house
they want to isolate and [ __ ] they want
to be able to drive but not drive but
they don't want to take a cab because i
don't know [ __ ] who wants to call a
cab but they will use an app to like get
somebody who's not a licensed driver to
come pick them up like technology is
kind of and this is not a complaint i'm
not like this is not me pointing
something out and saying this is broken
needs to be fixed but my observation is
technology has completely infantilized
us to the point in the modern world not
just technology
to the point where we have these
incredible expectations of what is and
and how life is supposed to be that's
why you have like you know a petition
with
over a million signatures or whatever
the [ __ ]
of a bunch of people telling hbo you
have to redo season eight of game of
thrones because we didn't like it oh my
god i mean think about it like this is a
culture
like like if you don't like it we'll
change it they put up a trailer for
[ __ ] a sonic the hedgehog movie and
people are so outraged by the character
of the cgi character's mouth
that the filmmaker has since apologized
taken the movie down and said that
they're going to
delay the movie until 2020 in order to
fix really what everybody doesn't know
oh my god and now you know i'm not
saying that's wrong i'm not pointing
this out and saying can you believe this
[ __ ] where we are but i get how it
happens you've got a bunch of people
sonic costs an ungodly amount of money
and whoever's making sonic is like well
the people who are going to want to see
this movie think the mouth is stupid so
let's [ __ ] fix that makes sense it's
sort of like free uh test marketing
absolutely makes sense but it enables
the audience or us human beings one more
example of like you know oh well life
could be exact life i can tailor it
exactly as i want yes easy it's easy and
that's
you can get your life yeah to
a place where you're comfortable and
like we're pretty much what you wanted
if you're lucky that should be the goal
in life it shouldn't be like get to the
top of the mountain it should be like
fashion a life for yourself that is
exactly in the world around you exactly
as you want it to be may you realize
your divinity in this lifetime you are
god shape your universe now that's yours
problem is
people shape their universes and then
they expect the rest of the universe to
go along to acquiesce but it's like
guess what if everybody's shaping their
own [ __ ] universes
some of those are going to line up it's
like oh
universes yeah and some are going to be
parallel opposite to everybody you stand
for and believe in but
you want that right you want everyone i
mean as americans don't we want
everybody the freedom to choose who they
want to be and what they want to do so
long as it doesn't [ __ ] hurt anybody
or something right but that's not the
case anymore we live in these filter
bubbles now where people aren't allowed
in and and isn't that the way the whole
world is going though like we were
filter bubbling before you know
everyone's like oh this country's
divided but
well you saw it early on on the internet
yeah i mean you were one of the and we
were talking about this before you
entered into that world 1995 95 but then
you became very you had said to me
i said what's the appeal of of you know
inserting yourself into that world and
like being active online and and you
said you which is interesting you wanted
to know the people that didn't were
going to see your movies you wanted to
know why you want to engage with them i
wanted to be able to talk to the people
that bought a ticket the only way you
knew how you were doing in your film
career back then was like uh the reviews
the chronicles but that's only a select
sampling of people
who didn't pay to see the movie they
sell it for free and this is not bagging
on critics i'm just saying that's an
unreliable metric for me yeah and then
the other metric is box office which
also is also it's
some
metric but also an unreliable metric i
wanted to be able to talk to the
individuals about tickets to be like
you know i used to do that and i still
do that for other people's movies and i
know how hard it is to make money and i
know how hard it is to budget and then
if you're leaving aside money for your
own entertainment you're going to be
choosy with what you do it's a friday
night you can only see one movie and
sure you picked mine
why the [ __ ] did you do that and
i think i might want to know you yeah
interesting we're like-minded but and
you were talking about that void that
void that that fills um you you
mentioned like you you're a kid and your
parents put your your artwork on the
fridge yeah how good that feels and how
we're all still i think about that a lot
look for validation yeah that's what
everybody wants man like at the end of
the day they want to be heard that's
what i think i think people
fundamentally need
three things food [ __ ] and to be
heard they need to eat they need to have
[ __ ] sex
um and i'm not saying that's a basic
right i'm just saying that's what human
beings [ __ ] need and you can break
that down to human contact or whatever
but i honestly think it's just flat out
sex they need someone else to come with
yeah that's that keeps the person sane
whole happy blah blah and love is you
know the [ __ ] human construct and
and you could you know [ __ ] is that
2019 kevin's been do what would what
would 1999 kevin smith say about love
that
um
i mean chasing amy is pretty [ __ ]
romantic i believe oh my god and i
believe in love absolutely i've been
married 20 years this year i'm a woman
but
as i tell her all the time because we
have this discussion because i'm
sexually obsessed with my wife still oh
big time yeah and and you write about it
in the book yeah very graphically that's
true i and and you know some people are
like yeah it's immature and [ __ ] but i i
just i'm a big fan of her and [ __ ] and
that hasn't really like
changed
so you know like
for me
like
sex is the is the currency that spends
more it's a more valuable currency
because
my love really tangible it's very
terrible but my love radar is completely
[ __ ] completely in what sense i get
love
everybody oh i see yeah from total
strangers bro i leave my house right 10
minutes
and and this is not me bitching or
bragging this is just no yeah [ __ ]
life i think it's important total
strangers will walk up to me and not
just feel like love your work people do
that like hey son bob and that feels
good yeah people will stop me and tell
me a profound story about how something
i did
intersected with their lives
and their father used to share the
movies with god yeah like they miss
their dad but the movies bring them
together and that's love that is
if i turned to those people yeah and
said can i stay at your house tonight
absolutely they say yes they might not
take a bullet for me but i've done
something my dopey work has done
something so profoundly wonderful for
them that they
give me a piece of themselves
[ __ ] love wait
i want to get back to how you feel about
this but i i need to tell you this uh
this is weird one of the i think it's
one of the only times this i can relate
um was when i was flying back from
new orleans to from doing jay and silent
bob reboot i've been doing that
character with we talked about
and i was wearing
my zack and mary
sweatshirt that i got as a rap gift um
it was so weird there was there was a
a woman
uh
across the aisle from me on the plane
who kept kind of looking over she was
with her daughter and
and i was so tired going back i just
remember being like i was not i was
slight they were taking photos and stuff
and i was like
mildly a new i had a moment of like come
on i'm sleeping on the plane and they're
taking photos
and she um she got up to go to the
bathroom one point handed me a note
handed me a letter this long note and
the gist of it was
her husband had died recently
and heart attack out of nowhere it made
me think of you and uh and one of his
favorite movies was zach and mary and
petit he would quote the character and
and it meant so much to her and was so
and she wrote it in such a beautiful way
i was weeping i was weeping reading this
thing and um you sat down you were like
please erase the photos don't [ __ ]
take my pictures
no
no i gave her i uh
i gave her
my i started talking i said thank you so
much you know this means so much and i
and i said how this is so weird i was
just coming from
you know we made that movie 10 years ago
and i was just i'm coming back from
having done it yesterday all day and it
brought me so much joy to do that
character again to be with my friends my
friend made this i it was just i was so
happy and i was and and made me think
about life and how this guy her husband
doesn't they don't have him in their
lives anymore so i gave her my
sweatshirt and um oh did you yeah yeah
that's dope dude
i
it's so weird i i would just like a
picture would have been enough well i
think it's classic well i
it's something there was something in
the air that was like this
guy i don't know i would i want to get
into a story like that that you know
what i'm just wearing it i don't wear
that sweatshirt very often i have i'm
not saying what a story about you but
yes of course but i'm saying what a
story she got for the rest of life she
was like i was on a plane and justin
long was wearing a zach and mary
sweatshirt and i wrote it was weird my
husband passed when
he literally gave me his sweatshirt this
is justin long sweatshirt that he got
from like zach and mirror maha dave
whatever his name was it was he would
love this yeah this is amazing we're
having a framed or [ __ ] i'm gonna
wear it because when i wear it i'll
think of my husband it fitter but you
know it was a perfect occasionally these
things happen in my life where i'm like
there's this means something i don't
know what it is i'm saying bro like the
way i see love is like i
have never stopped once love is open
i've never stopped loving the people
that i've loved right right i i still
love my high school girlfriend uh yeah
oh [ __ ] my high school girlfriend right
he's married right i'm married but like
that's the big difference so love i i
can free to trade with a lot of people
and stuff but
sex [ __ ]
true physical intimacy
that's the strongest currency because i
only share that with one [ __ ] but how
do you separate that love that you're
talking about that we're talking about
from
adulation or that the people who
well i've never you've never felt people
treating you differently or laughing a
little more at your jokes of course i
mean well seth rogen once said something
i thought was kind of interesting where
he was doing a lot of like stage work to
prep for
that one judd apatow movie about
stand-up comedy
yes i forget what it was called um but
anyway so he was funny people funny
people i had a little party
and it took that [ __ ] long
um so he said that like in order to get
ready he went and did a bunch of like
got up on stage yeah comedy again
but he was like i was doing comedy as
the guy who was in 40 year old virgin
and knocked up
he's like so for the first like 10
minutes
anything i said i gotta prove gets a
laugh oh right he's like but then after
that you know you actually you gotta
bring it funny yeah like all right now
you're just famous oh that's interesting
i was talking to my friend paul paul
downs he's a hilarious great writer just
a really funny person and he hadn't done
stand-up he said he's doing stand-up
again and
his experience has been
there's more pressure now now that
people kind of know who he is so it's
not like
you go and like there's a stranger up
there and you give them the benefit of
the doubt it's like
you go a little easy on them and uh let
them kind of no there's now he said he
feels this pressure right off the bat to
like
prove himself to like prove that
i well i feel that i that was my fault
in my world because i at one point i
made a conscious decision like oh
i'm gonna be me for a living like that
yeah i'm not just a filmmaker because if
i'm a director
then i gotta get hired to direct or i
gotta find the money to direct the film
or something like that but if i'm me for
a living well you can't really get fired
and you're you as you are a great
storyteller and you were telling stories
in movies and and these characters were
a vessel for you essentially you're
talking about your you never really left
i'm jotting like i am a great
storyteller i mean but you're right all
those stories that was like that the one
criticism i would always get i mean
believe me i get a lot but the one i saw
over and over again and not from like
film critics but just online when i
became a denizen of the internet people
on my message board
and then in other places
a general criticism of me and my work
are all of his characters sound like him
and i
never saw that as a bad thing ever ever
ever right i'm like the only cards i got
to play with are the kevin smith cards
so if you hear my voice and every one of
my characters then like mission
accomplished yeah well that's what i'm
going for and some people but that's not
the point i'm like it's my point like
and i'm not saying i'm right you're
wrong i'm just saying like that doesn't
bother me i'm like i remember one time
when i turned in the script for
what did i it was for six million dollar
man a rose script for the six million oh
wow and the producer was
kevin mischer whose name he wasn't the
producer then he was a studio head and
his
criticism
of the script his dismissal if you will
and this ain't a like pick and fight
thing this is just something that
[ __ ] happened my agent guy said he
said hey man did you hear back from the
studio and he goes yeah i talked to
kevin mitcher
and he said what do you say does he like
it and he goes
i don't think so i said why
he goes there's exact words where
this reads like a comic book
and my response was end
because that was like the point like
it's a comic book movie and that was 19
or nine let me see like 98 i want to say
maybe 99 or something like that also
that sounds like a dismissive
but it was definitely meant to be yeah
but to me i'm like respecting comic
books the point where that's what i was
going for and i'm like and also you
couldn't pick
like a worse dismissal of my work than
it's like a comic book exactly exactly
oh go on
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
is this what kind of provoked your your
new ideology about dogma i would say
part one of like i don't want to grow up
say the death of my catholicism but the
the
the dusk dogmo is a kid asking all the
questions you're supposed to ask really
when you know you're much younger
right but i remember that as being um it
was an investigation i eventually just
got to a point where i'm like this is my
own personal journey but i'm like
i have faith in in jesus
i also have faith in batman right you
know not that batman's gonna [ __ ]
come down from the sky and save me
literally but but then again neither was
jesus yeah i'm not i'm not saying like
praise batman instead of god but it's
like at a certain point i realized and
then it goes even when you invested in
those heroes i mean as a kid growing up
just like i invested in jesus exactly i
wonder if that actually helped prolong
your catholicism probably because i
believed you know not believed it
because who doesn't love a good hero
exactly and you're looking for answers
this is the greatest hero story of all
time like
superman can save planet earth you know
what i'm saying batman can save gotham
city
jesus
saved the world bro right universe when
he shows to sacrifice himself you want
to talk about the ultimate heroic
gesture i've already been pre-trained
to trust somebody in flowing robes yeah
who's looking out for exactly good and
talking good too and they're clear
enemies just like in the bible jesus had
his [ __ ] devil and batman's got his
joker and superman's guys lex lee i
didn't realize when you made dogma that
you were still you still believed in
what was that like for you when it when
it was received because i remember when
that came out and i i was my parents are
very catholic i remember them being
offended i remember kind of being oh i
thinking it was offensive like i can't
believe he did that i mean of course i
was knight i was
it felt punk rock to me that he was able
to like comment on that institution
having been raised so creatively on
thank you on life of brian
i felt like yeah oh my god that was that
religion totally this movie like this
movie believes in christ like it holds
up holds all the tenants of catholicism
the whole movie is predicated on the end
of the world based on the catholic
belief yeah about you know this
consecrated arch and [ __ ] like that so
the movie starts
going from jump going like this that's
true yeah yeah now so here's what's
funny right did that confound you then
when people when the catholic church
then was rejected it so publicly the way
they did no because i'm like it's got a
lot of ass [ __ ] now
so i knew they could never embrace it
but at the same time i don't think
there's a single church that isn't as
[ __ ] up doesn't mean they've got their
own problems yeah yeah but i mean if it
always occurred to me that like boy if
they get off their high horse and
actually watch the movie [ __ ] yeah
they'd be shocked at how on message
right this movie actually is you know
but they couldn't be bothered and [ __ ]
so
that was the beginning just like wasn't
your way clerks was me working out
you know where i was in life how it's
okay to not
do what everyone else is doing and
you're anointed by the you know you're
24 when that happens you make this movie
for a micro budget everyone knows that
story but what i had a chance to improve
like if you look at clerks and chasing
amy
maybe even a little bit of dogma
definitely clerks and chasing clerks was
94 amy was 97 7 but made in like 96
clerks made in 93 came out in 94. okay
amy made 96 came out in 97. um
if you look at him
you could see the last vestiges
of what might have been a pretty
interesting
human being a normal human being because
those movies were
the last thoughts i had
before i left normalcy that's so
interesting i entered a world of make
believe where things where anything was
possible where dreams came true right so
for better or for worse i mean but i
mean suddenly it didn't you no longer
had to be like wouldn't it be cool if
they did this in a movie you could just
go do that do it yes so the power what
does that do to you i mean well but
that's but
you can see what it does you just look
at my career attract me as a person and
stuff and it probably took me longer to
develop as a human being than it would
have taken without the arts and [ __ ]
without film without the infantilization
of like
what do you want to make pretend about
today for money kev so talk about one of
the things that stunted you in that way
when i was a kid jealous when i was in
my 20s i was just jealous like as an
artist i was jealous like there were you
know now i could recognize and guess
what it doesn't go away yeah but now i
you can process it better process and
realize what it is and like oh yes
realize it's attacking leave it behind
but back then
it just seemed to make sense like i'd
seen other people do it right richard
link later laid it out slacker yeah
independent film
um quentin tarantino with uh with
reservoirs
where they talk about totally with the
madonna song right it's like are you
kidding me like if you could just talk
about pop culture and that counts as
dialogue i'm gonna talk about star wars
[ __ ] yeah so you had just seen
reservoir dogs you've seen reservoir
dogs i just seen slacker robert of
course i've seen robert's stuff but his
he's not in rna as much because you know
he's he's insanely talented and he made
it like they're all talented right but
he's visually talented in a way of like
at least with quentin who is also
visually gifted he he composes insanely
well but i could find access to his work
and relate to it on the written word
level
robert's work is not like it's
impenetrable to me but it's like when i
look at
like jj i'm like oh like of course he's
j i could never in a million years do
that like when i look at spielberg's
work like oh i could never in a million
[ __ ] years do that they're like born
to do it like robert was born with a
camera in his hands and and it's not
just beautiful composition he's his own
[ __ ] dp and he could do like 96
setups in a day well you are so what i
would say about you you're stressed
i just i just i just you're a wordsmith
you are your words are you shouldn't
make me a filmmaker well but isn't that
what you know films can you could have
just been a screenwriter that's true but
my batters before me the generations
previous to me you know i could have
been like uh
william goldman like who wrote well i
may have never really princess bride and
then put your cassidy on the side right
but if i maybe picked one kraft and like
said i'm going to dedicate myself to it
like i'm just going to be a really great
screenwriter and practice and get good
and over and over again but but i didn't
never even had to do that think about it
my filmmaking has been so incredibly
self-indulgent because because nobody
like i'm an independent filmmaker well
isn't it how often does somebody tell
you to do another draft or another pass
right rethink your ideas when you're
independent the whole thing is you're
independent so you do what you want do
you take notes do you listen to other
people absolutely yeah i'm way i mean
especially
later in my career but i've always been
pretty good about it like moser was easy
to listen to because he
he cut right through the [ __ ] chuff
and you'd steal our sensibilities and
never hurt my feelings while doing it
like you've got nine buttons to this
joke just [ __ ] pick one they're all
funny but yeah you can't do nine it's
going to get tired right one and [ __ ] so
he'd go through the script he was
wonderful like here's a 160-page script
and he could turn you turn it into
120-page script just by exiting [ __ ] out
going you don't need this you don't need
this so i was always open to
cutting suggestions and it's not like
i'm like my [ __ ] don't stick you can't
tell me what to do but there does come a
certain point where it's like
well i understand what you're saying but
then it's no longer the thing i want to
do right right like that thing makes
sense i've gotten notes from like that
that totally makes sense but i just
don't want to do it right and not in a
childish way but it's just like
that's not part of what i want to be
adam siegel i worked with on cop out
once he said he described me thusly and
i'm sure he's described many people this
way and maybe this is an expression
other people have heard but i've never
heard it i thought it was adorable he
goes um working with you man he's going
you are the fluffiest [ __ ] cloud in
the world and you have an iron core so
at the center of all that fluff he's
going is something decidedly solid
and immovable yes because you want what
you want you know exactly what you want
but he's going you're very good at
including everybody yeah very good at
like not excluding people tearing all
ideas out and stuff and you incorporate
as much as you can but like there is a
certain point where you're like no this
is what it is well it's
to that um i at that point i recently
interviewed olivia wilde and we were
talking about she was talking about her
kid saw her movie last night and [ __ ]
loved my kid that's she loved it and i
was like did you love it i said [ __ ] i
was going to take you to see it today
she goes i would go back again today
yeah you i i'm she can't wait to see
like at one point she was like you know
when they were auditioning that movie
because kids and actors as well
that like she was up for
the part that
um
plays yeah and she's like i would never
like she's going that girl was bro she's
great she's absolutely she goes i love
her as an actress yeah like she's going
that was a part that was
you know the kid hates losing parts
because you know she's the only child
and that's just getting whatever she
wants it's not a spoiled way but yeah
yeah sure and so she has no frame of
reference for like oh you're going to
share these things now and yeah or
now she does yeah like after
after a year i'm out there auditioning
for movies
it ain't like [ __ ] like you know dad
world where it's like oh let me make
yoga
does that scare you that she is now on
this path of being an actress we talked
about it a little no not at all i'm
happy for her especially because she
like i i honestly i really like the kid
so much i'm in love with her performance
of jay and sam bob reboot and i spent a
lot of time with the footage so i get to
see it over and over again but i also
kind of just like
what she's doing where she is like she's
putting this weird career together that
like she's gonna do with me tarantino's
new movie yeah harley's in thank god bro
and like some people like i put up a
thing going like hey my kid got you know
she's in the trailer said of course a
bunch of people want [ __ ] out and be
like ooh she's only [ __ ] famous
because of you well that must be hard i
mean like we're talking talking about
earlier for me i'm like my point is i'm
like look yeah you're absolutely right
she's only [ __ ] famous because maybe
because she came out my dick and without
me she don't exist so yes but that don't
mean that i got a job it's like i could
catch i didn't make her a good actress
no yeah and i can cast her in my [ __ ]
you can blame me for casting her my [ __ ]
but like you can't pin it on me for
quentin casting her man like i told that
kid when she was like i want to go up
for quentin's movie i was like don't i
was like you're gonna get burned kid i
was like i want to go up for that movie
everyone wants to be in quentin's next
movie i was like you're just starting
man like are you kidding me i've read
jane fonda said she wants to be in it
you don't really have a hope in hell man
it's not because you're not a good
actress you're great you know i feel
about you but like that's a tough hill
man that's a go you go for it but you
gotta know that you chances of you
getting this or nilla none and she
worked [ __ ] hard not in the way of
like you know a movie montage i'm going
to prove you wrong dad but she just went
deep
deep went in for the auditions her
audition process was she can get lines
she decides to write a monologue oh wow
so she went in rocked monologue and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] next week heard back
uh she's wonderful but we ain't got
anything for her really and that was it
and her [ __ ] world crashed and oh we
all had to eat [ __ ] around here for like
two weeks like so you put in a call to
quentin you would think so my wife goes
like cockman well literally she was just
like what can you do and i was like i
could tell the kid that
it's a good lesson yeah i was like what
do you mean what can i do she was like
call him i was like you're out you're
[ __ ] down i was like number one i
don't talk to him that regularly yeah
certainly not gonna talk to him about
this [ __ ] number two
i've never had anybody call me up and
said hey cast my kid in the movie i
don't know how i'd react to it i know me
i'd probably be like
okay
but like him he ain't me and that's just
[ __ ] rude and in the long run
i can't do that
for this is a slippery slope yeah you
know what i'm saying like let's say i do
that and she finds out
like then you and me are [ __ ] the
antichrist forever we didn't she didn't
earn this blah blah blah i was like i
understand that we want to see the kid
happy but like
she knows this is the world she chose
like i've supported her not going to
college because she wanted to be an
actress and she knew
that like going into acting is 99
rejection yeah one percent if you're
lucky
someone says [ __ ] yes but most of the
time it is a constant it isn't
antithetical to the way the girl was
raised and brought up and has lived up
until this moment in time right a world
of yes and auditioning is not a world
[ __ ] night yeah yeah so naturally
like as a parent you're like oh i want
to [ __ ] i'd hate to see her hurt but
i told my wife i was like i cannot will
not i don't have that kind of juice yeah
i had that kind of juice i'm never
making that [ __ ] call you want to
save that juice and for never for her
yeah i would like to savor my [ __ ]
self like i was like it's it's a
band-aid on cancer like you don't want
that totally and so
the kid
pivoted yeah and she started working on
her music and then she put together an
album with her friend and [ __ ] and then
as the album was coming out all of a
sudden she got a call and they were like
uh
quentin wants you in the movie he loves
your audition wow
he doesn't know what you're going to do
but he wants you to be one of the manson
girls and boom she was in the [ __ ]
movie when you were her age did you what
what were your aspirations like what did
what did you imagine did you imagine
yourself being like i'm certainly not
celebrity my big dream was i wanted to
write for saturday night live really
yeah
i loved snl when i was in high school
and i didn't want to be on it i was
never that vain that i was like i want
to be belushi but i i was like i want to
be michael o'donoghue i want to write
for the show i want to write i want to
be ann beats i want to write sketches
and [ __ ] like that
um you know and every once in a while i
was going to be lauren michaels but i
you know i was more identified with the
sketch of the writing i wrote sketches
in high school and stuff so that was my
big dream i went to college in a
new school for social research e.g and
lag for filmmaking no not for film for
writing really yeah that was before i
was in the film this is when i was like
right out of high school i just wanted
to be a writer so back then i mean you
you touched on this
and your strength somebody with a
strength like that that's what you would
do with it you would become a you'd go
right it wasn't like not even in our
world yeah if you had a strength for
words like that didn't mean [ __ ] it's
like so what but like what
like what pharmacy you're gonna work out
right right so you still had company you
had no delusions of grandeur you were
like realistic i i not delusions of
grandeur but like i loved entertainment
yeah i loved actors i loved actresses i
loved being entertained at tv and movies
i was not a sports kid yeah and you know
i went beyond just simply being
entertained by them pre-internet i was
the guy that sought out the information
you know like how did that how does it
work you're curious and i was
knowledgeable yes you know and so you i
knew that like people made these things
for a living like it sounds so stupid
like the cannonball run
showed me like
this is what you want to do look how fun
not the movie itself but in their
credits they always show the bloopers
and everyone had such a good wait wait
wait this is so good i want to put i
have to pee so badly i put it talking
okay okay all right everybody had such a
good [ __ ] time tailing credits
of the cannonball run for those who've
never seen it is essentially a blooper
reel and uh hal needham and burt
reynolds made a series of car racing
movies that had a bunch of [ __ ]
famous people in himself
and so you know at the end of the movie
rather than just rolling credits they'd
roll credits with
picture with the cut scenes with uh you
know footage of people
blowing tapes actors breaking out of
character and laughing and stuff and
making each other crack up
and it was bliss it was better than the
movie itself to be honest with you and
like the movies were fun and you know
i'll always love them because my father
loved him and the bonding [ __ ] with my
dad but
man as much as he laughed at the movie
my old man loved sitting through the
credits even before there was a marvel
movie to sit through the credits for
sitting through the credits of like
cannonball run
and watching people
cracking up watching famous people like
laughing while they're in the middle of
a [ __ ] tank i just told you you could
handle your piss
i just ran out to pee and but that that
was formative watching watching my
father laugh at the end credits of
cannonball run not just laughing at a
movie but watching him laugh at famous
people having a good time enjoyment of
it well validation he hated his [ __ ]
job hated work like what did he do post
office right he hated it and he wasn't
even like walking the beat and should he
kiss that upsets you still right even
the fact that the fact that he had to do
that you get to do this
even the way you said the post office he
well he hated it yeah he he and i like i
have nothing but respect for kosovo yeah
he it could have been like you know
[ __ ]
church he hated church or do we know
actually just like that he hated his job
period and he never thought
well i don't know if he thought to or
maybe his generation or wasn't in his
makeup
to be like i hate my job maybe i'll just
get a better one or maybe i'll study and
get something that like i don't hate so
much yeah he was of a time and a place
or a mindset maybe he wasn't raised to
be thought of that thought that he could
do better but
he just got a job to pay for what he
really wanted which was the wife and the
kids like that was the important thing
he was never this guy that like i asked
him at one point dad what were your
dreams when you were younger and he was
like what do you mean like kind of
insulted a dream yeah like what i didn't
achieve them or whatever yeah but i was
like what do you like what do you like
what did you want to do
and he was like i did it i got married
and i had you kids and i was like what
about for a job and he was like well i
went to the post office to pay for that
so his dream was that yeah my dream was
like oh my god could you imagine if you
got to make movies right you know i used
to dream about being in love when i was
a kid and [ __ ] like that but i had a few
relationships throughout high school and
long-term ones and stuff like that so i
had the taste for that and i knew that
like all right well i've had some
satisfaction in terms of like being with
somebody or a life partner i was always
looking for like a life partner even
from a young age not just like i want to
[ __ ] around but that's an admirable
nestor well that's what your dad was
like too yeah i guess that's what i one
person one person only and she's
admirable that he did a thing that he
didn't necessarily love to together to
make it comfortable for you you're
baffling to one of his only begotten
children who understands his father more
than many many anyone else will probably
ever understand his dad with the
exception of maybe my mom
but like still as much as i understand
my dad and love my dad and absolutely
respect the choices he made i'm baffled
that that wasn't enough for me because
he never told me that it should not be
enough i didn't have parents that were
like you know go farther than us you
should want more than this or whatever
so well it's very selfless don't know
who which one you're doing
yes but why did i
what happened between
him and me why did he
why was family the most important thing
for him and me the most important thing
was
like well i should do something wrong
with my life i have people have to hear
me because the life that he created for
you allowed you to see beyond that
allowed you to dream beyond that i mean
it sounds cheesy but i guess
i've admired i've always admired my dad
for he chose a life that he loved i mean
he chose a career that he loved and i
think that's
rare he philosophy i mean even now he's
retired but he translates
latin i mean he translates he's
translating publishing still for fun
it's his hobby and and
i think in that way they're probably
only that way you are a lot like you are
like my dad that you do
what you love and and the fact that you
were at one point hung up on certain you
allowed jealousies or insecurities to
get in the way to inhibit um your
happiness that's but that's what the
work is about of course
like exercises
the jealous kevin smith the one who was
like
how many guys have you been with before
me that was
the most important who the [ __ ] is
finger cuffs yeah i'm like wait so you
had sex with who you
know what you look like naked and so
wait and now i've gotta wonder if i'm as
good a lover as that but that's what i
see on a regular basis like but that's
all that dopey male anxiety that but
relatable that's why that movie still
really holds up i mean i'm telling you
that i texted you after i saw that and i
was like you gotta make another one of
these because it's true no it's so true
so like i'm glad i only made one chase
amy because like that guy
well you said you then you had to stop
existing like i could because you moved
into this other yeah and so the movies
function as that like dogma functioned
as my
you know goodbye to to to a lifelong
passion to not just
like i describe like you know losing my
religion that sounds very dramatic at
very rem but
you know imagine that moment when you
found out
that santa claus was real spoilers but
just in case um we have a very young
audience
well you know cut that out like yeah
how there was a sense of betrayal of
like oh yeah like wait but everyone lied
to me and said they're adults adults who
are infallible and your parents are like
we're in on this [ __ ] lie who
eventually go like no we were just lying
in jail yeah but you imagine you know in
my world
i had that moment for
god well i had that moment for santa but
then you know folks had the audacity to
be like
but but jesus right well that's
real and proven right you know so like
this fantasy
was taken away
but this fantasy
was
endorsed further yeah so it goes deep in
your [ __ ] sticks around and stuff so
dogma
is me
kind of getting to that place of like oh
after
you know nearly 30 years of my life i
guess
i guess like i don't need this as much
anymore did it make you more anxious
when you started letting go of that
because there is a comfort in this bad
it's something yeah
sure
like you know when you read about these
people and comforting that have to get
deprogrammed from i'm not comparing
catholicism to a cult or anything like
that but like
they'll talk about like the kids that
can um
get out of scientology or
some of them like have gotten out of the
um
uh um uh megan phelps who got out of the
westboro baptist right right like she
was raised in that faith they must love
you from the
from the from the jump yeah and then to
one day
deny that part of you like the
foundations of who you are you have to
rip out a lot of who you are and it goes
away with it so dogma is the beginning
of it but smodcast
sitting across from scott mosher for
like [ __ ] 12 years and doing podcasts
is that's where you could actually hear
me
kind of come to terms with the fact that
you know and this again i'm not saying
this is the way it is this is just what
i believe yeah but i come to kind of
agree with moser where i'm like
oh this is it well this is somebody you
look up to you admire his intellect like
george carlin one of the absolute
smartest people
and the most pragmatic and practical
yeah and absolutely fallible and and be
the first to admit he doesn't know
everything and stuff but like well i've
met many people in this world
moshe is not only funny and [ __ ]
someone you can do on and [ __ ] but he
just [ __ ] makes flat-out sense
exactly he would be a great politician
if politics were based on common sense
like this is a guy
i would choose to fix any problem in the
world yeah you drive differently than
you are in life yeah
it's interesting that you because you
are i drive like an [ __ ] that's what
we're getting you drive like an [ __ ]
and you were one of the most chill i
mean
well let's go also i i want to get to
2008 when you started smoking because
you're now
known as what you're one of the more
famous pot smokers to be fair i was
famous for pot smoking before i started
smoking yes because of my character from
1994 forward i get tagged as a star
that's true
and i was stunned to learn smoking weed
until 2000 but so the what was the early
obsession with why well you you must
have been around a lot of people smoke
pot and no no
that's just jay when jay was a kid for a
minute
he smoked weed
when i left for film school he was
straight edge when he came back from
film school he had had he'd gone to weed
he'd gone to booze
and weed so suddenly he was in that
world so he i i took the character of
jay from jay but standing outside the
convenience store and dealing yeah that
just came from the local kids in
leonardo okay who just hung out in front
of the place and sold weed but didn't
some of them didn't even sell wheat some
of them just hung out inside outside the
store which always baffled my my [ __ ]
uh
mind why why the [ __ ] anywhere you could
hang out in the world yeah convenience
store would you hang out in front of the
convenience store like you're and we
were so public if your parents drove to
town they'd be where the [ __ ] are we
hanging out in the community
anyone can see you so you can't really
get up to no good yeah because there's
not a f you don't have it doesn't seem
like you have a fondness for that aspect
of their personality it's not like the
mall where it's just like wow there's a
bunch of things to do yeah
you're literally just leaning on the
wall it always fascinates me well it's a
i guess it's a place for it's a public
place for kids to go and you when you
don't want you can go in and get like uh
kind of contraband you can get
cigarettes there and you get pornography
magazine you know like that was back
when
a was like porn like a playboy was was
everything how was everything i would
think about it you got to think
i mean i'm not saying these poor kids
but like
kids today
you don't know how i mean it's too
accessible nice not like there's no
mystery now you can you could go online
and
watch right up close
anal sex when we were kids we were like
you know oh my god could you imagine if
you've got a hand job that would be way
too much and now you can literally go
online and watch that crazy the most
insanely
up-close and personal sex acts on the
planet and they're completely [ __ ]
normalized for a generation because
they're like oh well i'm watching this
what you know you if you can see it you
can be it but that's why you look back
you know if you're a kid now like what a
high expectation
i can't imagine i was grateful
for somebody to [ __ ] kiss me it seems
that now yeah kids today if
they engage in any sort of physical
relationship expect the entire [ __ ]
menu dude yeah like expect to do it
expect god i can't imagine that's crazy
it makes it makes a lot of those early
movies even like clerks and stuff which
at the time seemed so scandalous and
they were talking about such real [ __ ]
and like sexual stuff it now there's an
innocence in a way to them do you find
that do you do you revisit those ever
and think like god
there's yes except there's still
something in each one of those where
it's like well that's still there's
still heaven they're still that's true
it's normal yet there's like there's a
conversation about sucking one's own
dick
that that has not been normalized
hopefully it won't life could be a dream
[Music]
i just never really went into my high
school girlfriend who i did it for like
12 years oh um and it's like i've talked
is she in your work i mean is that in
your work yes and chasing a relationship
in the world as well you can see her in
the movies and stuff my brother is my
first audience the first person that
made me think like oh like i wrote
something that made him laugh i
controlled his [ __ ] emotions how
interesting kim was like my first fan
she was incredibly supportive she like
pushed me creatively not pushed me like
you better do better but just like no
you want you she was inspiring and a
playmate was just like like let's go
make pretend let's go and you wanted to
make her laugh i mean yes what 12 years
yeah on and off from like uh the time
like from 1986 we just passed what what
what is i only know this because i
[ __ ] used to write it on every piece
of paper in high school um our when we
started dating was 5
25
86 we just passed 525 so every are you
still in touch yeah i mean yeah
absolutely i've never really fallen out
of each other's lives but um she's
married on marriage but it's not a like
you know only [ __ ] star-crossed like
she was there for the building of me and
in many ways responsible
for
who i became she just never made me feel
stupid for wanting
to be in there yeah oh that's huge and
so many people you know of course
come on you gotta have a backup that's a
hard community oh why are you it's a
hard thing to be challenging people [ __ ]
like that it's hard to even admit to
somebody that i want to do that i mean
that's what you dream who do you think
you are together as kids like you know
and like the kids do in high school but
she and i were
like two peas in in a pod and very
similar and stuff like that but i always
looked up to her because she knew
exactly where she was going in life and
her path and she was you know on the
more traditional like apply to these
colleges she went to carnegie mellon and
she like yeah like super bright i i
think i can recognize that person in
some of your movies i mean
you know up to alyssa jones is
definitely joey adams but all the girls
and clerks i mean both of the girls and
clerks are basically two sides of kim
and uh and that's just something you
haven't talked about i mean that's some
no because when i started doing podcasts
like um
i was and still am
like uh married yeah
so that's what you should be talking
about
no no it's just not something you want
to delve into yeah and out of you know
respect respect for who you're with but
now big part of my like growth process
in life and why i make the movement
shift
is to get beyond
traditional
definitions of things like when chasing
amy there's the scene where they're on
the swing set
and holden is sitting there going like
he's talking about the standard
definition
and alyssa is really like baffled by a
little frustrated with his
like you know about love
sex is about penetration he's like isn't
that the standard definition
these things were defined for me and
you're open to early on her world view
but you just hadn't been exposed to that
very much so and it's a movie ideology
yeah based on movies it's not even my
parents sat me down and told me sure
like i'm a romantic at heart based on
like [ __ ]
like a movie guy love movies movies call
to me i make movies for a living
and movies are the best part of us when
you when you put them on display because
it's only two hours of human being or a
fake human being's life right and in
that two hours you get a lot [ __ ]
done including show the entire [ __ ]
span of a relationship right up to
heavenly happily ever after and invest
in in a human human uh behavior and
you're done in two hours and you're
lucky maybe you get a sequel and you get
to check in on those characters but
that's it but the real world lasts a lot
longer than two [ __ ] hours right
chasing me was was
revolutionary for me i had not seen that
because in in many respects it's a
traditional roma and it's very romantic
it's a rom-com that like
you know it's so organically done and
well acted and shot but it's also um
really breaks that mold love is not this
concrete thing there's well chasing amy
was the one that solidified my career we
were out the door on mall rats and [ __ ]
like written off and whatnot really
totally um you know the movie cost five
and it made like two and right how much
i would also like make fun of it and
[ __ ] chasing amy was the one that
like brought us back and people were
like and you know all the criticism was
like he's back and he was i felt very ll
cool j like don't call to come back
years but
i get it like critically speaking
that movie is very important for my
career as important as clerks because
it means i get to stay in the room gets
me into the room mall rat shows me the
door ironically although it would age
well but still like if i was shown the
door and i stayed out and i got out and
stayed out that's it even if ball rats
has a renaissance years later you're one
hit wonder guy yeah and i'm the [ __ ]
like me maybe i'm not in film at all
anymore yeah what would you do chasing
amy though that's the one that [ __ ]
if it weren't
what would i be doing
if you had to leave the game and
i mean now you know i used to think i
wanted to own a comic book store but now
i have for like 22 years so it's like
all right well there's always that but
yeah i before film i
i always assumed i'd own a deli because
i know how to make a sandwich uh-huh
then she's really good with that sort of
thing thank god
joey was on board with chasing amy
because that movie is the story of our
relationship right
and thank god joey was like oh do you
want to write a movie in which you
show yourself for the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you were who [ __ ] like
couldn't get over the fact that i was
more sexually adventurous than you
and i get to play that part
go ahead kevin wow you know what i'm
saying that movie functions as one
90-minute apology and you were together
throughout the the whole making of it
yeah wow there's emotional pain to get
to that
stuff
and you know realizing that like oh my
god like
the poor girl like
had to deal with this no wonder she was
baffled like you know i'd look at her
face sometimes where i'd be like
jealous over something and she would
look at me like
where does this
come from like i'm what i'm attracted to
about you is your confidence and
yourself yeah
but you had never had this
was part of it like you had never dated
anybody she was beautiful i mean was it
on the fact that very profoundly uh
affected me and and still does to this
day not in the way of like all right
pine over we're wonderful friends yeah
but
the way that holden met you know alyssa
and his whole
life view was challenged not because
like hey she's gay but just like
i love this person
so i should be in a relationship with
them because that's the standard
definition and her frustration with like
again with the standard like yeah it's
not what they told you it is it's
whatever you want it to be chasing amy
the process of me writing chasing amy
she would say because
i would handle these pages that
like scenes
would play like versions of
conversations or arguments we had
and then play like quasi apologies where
she was like yeah yeah he knew he was
wrong and we're getting some good art
out of it and i get to play this [ __ ]
part and
it probably helped the relationship go
longer than it would have and not by
virtue of the fact
that like oh i gave her a job you talk
about this in your book tough [ __ ] is
the book and it's it's so good um but
after the experience you had on cop out
which is the first movie you made that
you didn't write right where are you
after that movie i mean creatively cop
out like i was at a weird impasse in my
career after like zach and mary for some
reason that movie was i was convinced
was gonna make 100 million because
everybody told me like oh my god the
knocked up guy in this [ __ ] story
like there's no way this doesn't [ __ ]
do 100 million and wound up doing the
standard kevin spent 30 million that
kind of broke my brain because i was
like oh my god i ruined
seth rogen like i was actually here he's
on a [ __ ] roll oh yeah yeah so i was
susceptible to do something that i
wouldn't normally do he writes and jeff
robinov who was running warner brothers
at the time he loved zach and murray and
stuff and he was like why don't you come
over here and [ __ ] make a movie and i
was like okay and he's like we got this
movie called
a couple of dicks and it's [ __ ] i'm
down for that oh yeah i was like all
right man we're putting it together
right now what do you think about bruce
willis and i was like oh my god bruce
willis i love [ __ ] bruce bull it's
like moonlighting was my [ __ ]
spirit like oh my god great dialogue i
[ __ ] i i love it to this day it's
like the back and forth and [ __ ] david
and maddie and plus like he's a jersey
guy chris armstrong
he's great as well but i mean and he's
like all right let me see if i can work
this out and then he called me the next
day he was like uh what about tracy
morgan i was like i [ __ ] love tracy i
worked with him on chainsaw strike back
and stuff title changed while we were
mid-production they went to the networks
and said
would you run ads for a movie called a
couple of dicks
and they were like not before nine
o'clock and that was when people still
watch television and marketing was you
know like how else are we supposed to
tell people about this and so they told
us early on like two weeks into
production like you guys have to change
this title
and uh we never knew what it was gonna
be some of the suggestions were so weak
sauce and then ultimately wound up with
cop out so what what was it about it
that was
an experience you didn't want to
recreate who would ever want to work
with somebody who doesn't want to be
there right that's a heartbreaking top
of the mountain yeah heartbreaking and
finding out that at the top of the
mountain
nobody gives a [ __ ] well you had
mentioned this one of your and i there's
a theme that keeps coming up that i've
noticed is that one of your impetus for
wanting to do this at all was seeing
your dad
laugh at the outtakes for cannonball run
and i was i had to run to the bathroom
so i couldn't so smart well way to tie
it together you're absolutely right
movie making should be fun the joy of it
first and foremost yeah like
i you know i know some people like
christopher nolan i'm sure would be like
hey man it's about the art and blah blah
and god bless and that's why he makes
the movies he makes he's very successful
but for me the only reason to pursue
this is because we're getting away with
murder by having fun as adults the way
we did as children they get us money and
the moment they figure it out we're all
[ __ ] up
we got a good thing going yes so we
robbed a bank that's why i love so i'll
i'll watch out takes you know if i can't
sleep or if i'm having a bad day
outtakes from like step brothers or
absolute joy you sit there like
watching people
crack each other up and and that's how
you know like you know how [ __ ] funny
you have to be
to make will ferrell laugh before justin
long laugh or seth rogen break character
i still remember that no i don't want to
labor the zach and mary point but like i
still remember getting to do that go
toe-to-toe with seth and it was a joy
there were moments on new girl him break
up where he's like where he because he
was
oh man i'd love it so in the scene where
he's just the
he's like well how do you he goes you're
not in my demographic he goes uh
what's your demographic and you're like
do you like [ __ ] he goes yeah you go
not you
and he goes okay well there were a
moment aid in character as much as he
could but when he broke
it was messy breaking oh you can see it
on youtube but you can find it if you do
like justin long seth rogen zack and
mary outtakes uh so you do you have this
experience on cop-out which is the
opposite of
what you're soaking up when you watch
outtakes right it's like you know it's
the that
to be fair
any day
that number one wasn't there yeah
was pure joy oh yeah yeah like every
because i was making a movie don't
forget and tracy morgan that's what i'm
saying we weren't talking about b-dub
but
i was also making yeah tracy morgan yeah
he was legit one of the funniest human
beings yeah lived so
and generous right incredibly generous
you're talking about a man who was going
through a harsh about with his diabetes
right and
was physically debilitated
but still [ __ ] like
running around like he was actually
running around in real life but
physically could not
but still pushing through for just to be
funny yeah yeah um and so what you know
he
and everyone on the crew who kind of saw
what was going on and [ __ ]
tripled quadrupled the love yeah so
whenever we didn't have to deal with and
and there were moments where b-dub
didn't you know
hate the whole [ __ ] thing like
but tracy's qualities were probably
highlighted because of the distinct
absence of them in b-dubs the only
problem was they most of the scenes they
shared together so rare
is rare that tracy was on his own but
thank god tracy was there yeah with
b-dub because
he he was able to make things like
lighter but so you're working with
somebody like that and the experience is
not it's unfortunate because it's not
what it could be well it's like you came
into church and pissed into baptism yeah
we're here to have fun yeah
after the heart attack do you remember
being conscious of like your impending
death yes because the guy told me i had
a 20 chance of living oh my god it was
great it was awesome mark laden i've
told the story many times but he said uh
he's like uh yeah it's what i thought
you know you're because he went through
my groin with this uh my femoral artery
to my heart and then they looked at my
lady the artery goes across the heart it
was 100 percent occluded that means
fully blocked and that's why i was
having a [ __ ] widowmaker i didn't
know what it was called he goes uh yeah
you're 100 blocks so we're going to go
as fast as we we possibly can but he's
going before i go you're a comic book
guy right you like comics i was like
yeah yeah he goes okay this heart attack
you're having right now has a name it's
called the widow maker in eighty percent
of the cases of a hundred percent
occlusion like you got the patient
always dies but you're going to be in 20
expect i'm good at my job and he
disappeared in my crotch and saved my
[ __ ] life so what why would he say
that to you right before
you had all the confidence
exactly
um and it was it was amazing to have
that much truth and i'm glad he did
because let [ __ ] know in case
they've got some [ __ ] to tie up some
[ __ ] they want to say and did you did
you take that opportunity i did and it
was more
reflective than anything else um because
they you know asked me if i wanted to
talk to jennifer they got jennifer on
the phone like do you want to talk to
your wife oh my wife's on the phone and
i said no
because
i knew that if i talked to her
that would have been it i would have
died suddenly that 20 i was going to be
in like in the
because
once i talked to her then you said your
goodbyes whatever like some version of
that or like what
so i just figured give me a little bit
of a mental edge throw your hat over the
wall
if you don't talk to her
you got a reason to get through this
like you didn't [ __ ] talk to jen
before you died right you better make it
through otherwise you can be [ __ ] mad
interesting so it was a little bit of a
motivator as well yeah so but it's very
romantic kind of famous when i was
laying there you weren't tempted to
record anything i was like can i get a
podcast really i mean like they were
they were more preoccupied
saved my life than me saving my thoughts
that's a good point but uh i i
reached the place of like i was not
scared i was not
sad i was not like mad or anything i was
just like like i reached this weird
clarity of oh i get it now this is
graduation day like this thing i've been
afraid of my whole life of ending and
not being at the party anymore in life
going on without you like
it's like graduation you're done like
you were happy to be done with high
school there was a sense of
i don't have to do this [ __ ] anymore and
not i love life don't get me wrong but
like
there are a bunch of pressures that we
don't think about on the day-to-day
because they're just
you know woven into the fabric of life
above ground because on the day-to-day
i'm just you're like hey man i'm happy
to be doing this this is what you know
and that's the reality but in the moment
of
um you're you have an 80 chance of dying
suddenly it doesn't
matter anymore none of that matters oh
yeah like that [ __ ] your perspective
completely [ __ ] shifts and you're
like and then what's the clarity like oh
what are you left with then like stay
above ground yeah that literally it
survived like [ __ ]
like just yes if you're going to be here
yeah be here when you were on the table
there and he tells you you have 20
chance were you thinking about an
afterlife were you thinking like did you
even consider like well maybe there'll
be something else maybe i'll see the the
light of the year
because i thought that's hypocritical
it's so weird
you know i thought if the god would be
like you made dogma go [ __ ] yourself oh
man so i wasn't going to presume upon
that relationship and
no and i'm glad i didn't spend a lot of
time
worrying what was next and
you know dealing with some christian
judeo rules that were implanted in me
from birth that weren't my choice or
whatever the [ __ ] i'm glad i wasn't
sitting there
i'm not mean this is an insult to
anybody but wasting time yeah i did was
spend my time thinking about what was
important who i loved and and what at
the end of the day did this work out and
i was like yeah it's stopping early but
you can't complain this has been a
[ __ ] magical carpet ride and like
here it is and so be it i didn't think
about
what's next and i understand like why
people want to hear about heaven and
even hell because we're
we're arrogant human beings are arguing
we want to think that like
no all this was for something
there is no good way out of this world
it's all bad and painful
um and
not just physically but you know [ __ ]
spiritually emotionally it's
soul-crushing is the thing we don't want
to talk about or think about because
it's the inevitable and and beyond our
comprehension so then so that motivates
the nokia so i'll be vegan i'll do
whatever it takes to keep doing this
well that and like you know i knew i was
leaving behind people who were going to
be sad i wasn't around anymore but i
also knew they'd be fine okay this is
this is going to be
the speed around four minutes uh what is
your most commonly used emoji the thumbs
up okay good thumbs up
instead of just typing back copy i put
the thumbs up being i understood oh my
god you pose a bit like that in pictures
too yeah uh if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play and why uh hockey and i would
be a goalie and uh because it's
metaphor for life right like uh the
people are
coming out you gotta block
you know everything that comes at you
and uh
okay yeah this is a challenge for you
too because uh first of all i can't i
don't know how you still eat vegan and
and smoke weed yeah is that hard for you
not to have tons of snacks so it's
honestly not hard at all to be vegan
there's nothing i missed you don't get
snacky when you're stoned there's a lot
of vegan
so
stuff
fine there if you like sugar so what's
your favorite snack chips also vegan
your favorite if you could have one
snack food for the rest of your life one
snack for the rest of my life um
back in the day probably would have been
peanut
m great i think christian's but the
miller's not the milk chocolate now it's
not a factor and they make p they make
vegan versions and stuff it's not quite
the same
um i would say
go to snack
um
i mean
peanut butter i use a snack swedish fish
okay um favorite movie of all time and i
know this is gonna be hard uh uh
jaws jfk do the right thing the last
temptation of christ the man for all
seasons one of those okay i knew it was
gonna be fast uh if you have dinner with
three people dead or alive you've never
met who who would they be dead or alive
but they had to be real yeah it's not
like batman um
no
could be real
so i can't use jesus either
oh you can't even existed but there's no
proof there no okay let's say he did
exist well then let's say batman
oh [ __ ] we're right there just making it
all right forget the speed so jesus
batman okay
because come on man bruce wayne would be
fascinating yeah and okay he'd be
sitting there talking to jesus who could
be like
i could probably fix things with your
parents
but then i wouldn't be batman
i'd have no need for to be a vigilante
that's what would make the dinner so
interesting man see if like who breaks
first who fixes who your new emoji just
becomes the head exploding and the third
one barack obama okay well the favorite
muppet i was trying to go deeper than
barack obama but he seems like an
interesting guy yeah and i'm not just
like you know hopefully a bunch of
people aren't like [ __ ] you
but i mean as a person
even people who didn't like his politics
i have to admit it seems like cool to
hang out with really cool guys
you could hate his politics
and also like just yeah i i and i'm you
know
nothing wrong about it yeah no need to
go that's your choice you pick me
good um
who's your favorite muppet who's my
favorite muppet um
fozzie ah yeah oh yeah it makes perfect
sense did you get either x-ray super
x-ray vision or super hearing which
would you choose
super hearing
if you had to be one age for the rest of
your life what would you wait i don't
know if i want to choose
super excited that was too
easy quick i mean what do i care if you
have super hearing then you're hearing
people go like oh my god did you see
yoga hosers right and he thinks james is
all about
any better like well you're reading that
so why would you want to write exactly
yeah so supervision like see through
guys
yeah and you have to see through [ __ ]
well then oh i can't turn it off oh i
can see no like ah everything that's
drastic
i gotta revise that question
it'd be awful either way
to be super powerful
a cacophony of sounds
i could hear see through like that'd be
useful because you could tell people
like without them busting open al
capone's fault you'd be like nothing's
in there right
like you're serious i'm like yes you
solve cool crimes um if you could have
if you had to be one age for the rest of
your life physically speaking what would
it be 16. um beetle stones
beetles what would you want your epitaph
to read
um
he made clerks remember
and he was occasionally self-effacing
i'm just interested in keeping that [ __ ]
alive like i told my kid man the moment
i [ __ ] dropped dead you turn on the
[ __ ] black and white t-shirt machine
it is your job to keep me my memory my
work alive you turn on that [ __ ] put me
on a jersey yeah at least make a jersey
of me
make an earn again keep my [ __ ] alive
why uh
why the jersey why the hockey jersey all
the time it but it was a fat guy's moo
moo it does there's a lot of covers you
can gain or lose 20 pounds without
people necessarily knowing what it is
it's like a dress um
my friend i don't have time to properly
thank you uh because jennifer's chomping
at the bit i know you shut the [ __ ] up
i like you better toward the end of that
movie
my time with you in the past my creative
time with you in the past has been a joy
a [ __ ] joy and and it's been it's
always so fun being in the sandbox you
and me were bound forever because we
went into the trenches with that walrus
came out alive walrus [ __ ] yes make
people always [ __ ] yes and have people
still to this day going like how did you
manage to pull up made my mom cry dude i
know he told me that and and i can't
thank you enough for giving me that that
chance uh
and this has been the best my i'm not
good at signing off but uh but i'm gonna
do it with with christian we're gonna
talk about it coming up um but thanks
buddy
[Music]
well that
happened
well that happened oh it's sure do i
sound like him oh yeah that's pretty
good well that happened oh my god but it
was so fun it was so
fun to play that character oh my god we
get it you had really so much fun
playing a gay porn star
i can't stress this enough oh my god and
then and kissing bran didn't
don't get me started
uh that was really fun to listen to he
is just a it's he's a great talker this
is going to sound insulting a word kevin
smith yeah he's a word chemist man
uh he is
just the ultimate smooth talking nerd
yes you know what i mean
like we've talked before
on the show about nerds and how i think
a big component of what makes a nerd a
nerd is their social awkwardness and
their
they often stumble over their words he
doesn't have that he doesn't have that
he's like he's like a hep cat
is that a nerdy thing to say
yeah but you know what i mean but it's
it applies it's a nerdy cool word
it's it's perfect for what you think
what you're talking about he's like a
nerdy hep cat in fact he calls people
cats
oh right remember that i haven't heard
him do it in a while but like sir does
he call people sir and i call himself
yeah
uh he really does he's an incredible
speaker and i i meant to mention this
he's like an orator i meant to mention
this in the introduction but uh
he wrote a book that people should read
too called tough [ __ ]
and you that you reference in the
interview oh yes but i read it a few
years ago and it's
a great
great read because
it's i mean if it's interesting it's
about his life but it's about sort of
how he
rose to um independence in the film
industry yeah in entertainment in
general i guess
but uh he's just so good at putting
words together as a writer and a speaker
yeah that it's a really entertaining
read he's also so relatable and
accessible for creative people i i've
known a lot of creative people in my
life who who like kevin and from all
different creative fields you know um
because there's something very
diy about the way he rose to prominence
in in in his field you know
even first with movies that's a nerdy
way of saying it diy i've never
very sweet nerd um
yeah
but yeah diy that's funny oh i've never
heard you say well we've never heard
anyone say that well you said hep cat i
know
well i guess kevin smith is running
robbie robinson
by the way i'd like him to rub off on me
yeah especially not literally
but uh
i would love to have that gift of gab
i know that's nerdy too
oh my god
what's happening
like yeah you re of the mouth
[Laughter]
yeah he he's inspiring in that first
with clerics like i remember thinking
as as a
burgeoning creative young
man [ __ ]
yeah also nerdy bob
she's saying really nerdy things
prime hunting season
but
uh but he uh yeah i mean that's
inspiring but then what he did with
podcasting what he continues to do with
podcasting and
i would say his second iteration as a
filmmaker so he went from like which
you could argue isn't
you could argue isn't as
whatever you might not like it as much
as the first um
and i can make arguments for both and
what i mean is
after he did
a series of movies about his life
you know
from personal experience clerks chasing
amy um
he talks about this even like jersey
girl uh he went and made he started
doing podcasting and then
started cultivating all of these other
stories and that's how tusk was made it
came from the podcast but then he went
off into this and he started it's
culminated with him smoking weed when he
started smoking weed yeah he started
making these movies like
tusk and yoga hosers and and
yeah i mean it they're obviously tonally
very different movies but um you could
argue that creatively he
continues to take these wild chances and
like them or or or not
um
he is a true
artist i know that sounds pretentious
but he really like marches to the beat
of his own drum and he edits his own
movies too which should be noted he is
it's weird though he's a total artist i
agree but
he also
downplays in a lot of ways
his art and oh my god
because he says you know for me it's all
he talks about this in the interview he
said for me it's all about having fun
he makes it sound that simple and he and
he says you know i i'm not the kind of
director that
you know quinn tarantino or some of
these other some of his contemporaries
are
he's like he referred to himself as a
carpetbagger he's a director he's a
writer but i really just you know i just
do it for fun and and he talks about uh
you can't get fired for being kevin
smith or something yeah he is that's
sort of what he became after
that era of filmmaking when he started
doing podcasting
i think
kappa probably inspired that he wanted
it he became a brand
exactly and he and he's
said versions of this to me where he
wanted to take control creatively and
and didn't want to he did a very like i
guess infamous thing when he made red
state um he was something i he's talked
about regretting where he went to
sundance and
opened it up for bidding um and there
were all these
uh all these independent studios there
and he said basically [ __ ] you to all of
them
and i'm going to buy it for a dollar i'm
going to buy it myself or like scott
moser bit on his producing partner bid
on it and he said sold it for a dollar
to his pr and he and he
released it himself and took it on the
road so he even angered the independent
film world uh which you could argue is
like
again it's kind of this is also a nerdy
thing to say it's kind of punk rock
it's
nerdy for a nerd to say punk rock but
it's cool for a punk to say punk rock is
it i think so punk rock how many punk
rockers are there you sid vicious yeah
no that's what i picture what picture
punk uh but getting back to those uh uh
chasing amy and
um
clerks those movies for a second he
talks about that as those those in dogma
he talks about those experiences as
being ways of letting go of certain
parts of his that's right upbringing you
know he talks about chasing amy it was
kind of letting go of his
jealousy and in dogma is letting go of
his faith that he had growing up so
everyone does that to some extent in
their lives you know they have
experiences that change them and that
shake free something that was in them
and now no longer yeah so yeah but it's
interesting that he has
those experiences documented on i know i
know you know for
all time yeah it's really cool actually
and he can reference them as
look how much i've grown look but then
he said something to me once that was
kind of heartbreaking that it was recent
actually i i think we referenced this
where i i re-watched chasing amy and um
and and fell in love with it again it's
it's like
it's so it really more than holds up
it's uh
to me it did anyway and um i just found
it to be so
moving and romantic and and
uh i texted him about it and asking him
to you know make another one he wrote
back something that was kind of
heartbreaking he said
you know i don't think i can make that
movie anymore because i don't have those
experiences anymore i just don't know i
have no frame of reference for for that
he mentions this he does yeah yeah along
those lines he talks about the
difference between love and sex yeah
i don't think i've ever heard anyone
draw this distinction between love and
sex in this way there's more value put
on sex
than love yeah that's interesting well
he started by saying he's had
ex-girlfriends that he still has love
for
however he only has sex with one person
his wife so that's more special to him
but then he started talking about his
fans and how and and it and not
arrogantly at all and this is i know he
has an incredibly oh my god oh god yeah
following huge fiercely he's talking
about how people come up to him
constantly who love him he gets that
love from so many people
that i started to feel
like it the whole concept of love has
been diluted for him
people cultivate a
a very real much more real relationship
it makes sense it's funny that uh i
don't know if you realize that you did
this but he he
swears so frequently in such a casual
way that you started doing i think
that's funny he was just rubbing off
that's [ __ ] funny and you were like
oh man that's yeah this one [ __ ]
movie i did was uh it was great i uh
i had such a good [ __ ] time i don't
really oh
you don't normally do that you're not a
casual swearer no no no i still have
like little
you know
i try to reserve it i also like that
word [ __ ] it so i like talk talk
i'd like to reserve it
um
yeah use it make it count yeah exactly
he doesn't make it count no he uses it
like it's the yeah uh i thought it was
hilarious when he you went to pee
and
he kept going yeah
there's a lot that was impressive about
that whole thing so
first
how about the fact that he keeps going
and he stayed on track yeah
like he was talking to a person second
impressive thing
you come back
and then
right away pick up the conversation well
thanks but also and you didn't know what
he had just said well you're bearing the
lead the one thing i'm most proud of
okay
but you re-enter the conversation in a
seamless way and you go yeah totally so
well i i knew he was talking about he
was talking about the same thing he was
talking about outtakes from cannonball
run
it was like i don't know how much he
could have said about it and third the
final the most impressive thing which
i'm sure you know
how did you pee that fast yeah thank you
well okay it's not i don't know if it's
a compliment you might it you ruptured
something that you like
you push too hard and hurt yourself or
you peed in your pants on the way i peed
really fast and his bathroom is not far
from where his office is okay but i was
still impressed by myself and i'm glad
you noticed that uh i was wondering if
the term peter pan complex is
necessarily pejorative
it is right
because if it's not i think i would say
that he has a bit of one and i was
thinking that throughout and i might you
definitely do
but throughout he was talking about
you know his love of comic books and and
i
and mixton
throughout the whole interview i think
were his struggles with
letting go of things and get growing up
in a way
um and not to say that 50 year old men
can't be really into comic books and
stan lee but there's a sort of a
juvenile element yeah i think and then
at the end when you asked him what his
if you could pick one age to live as for
the rest of his life he without missing
a beat he said 16. oh wow and no guest
has ever oh interesting said they'd want
to be that i can remember yeah has said
they'd want to be a kid again i think
with him specifically like look what he
gets to do he got to live out all these
child he continues to live out these
childhood fantasies if you watch jay and
silent bob reboot it's
in that movie he there's so many he gets
to
it's almost like he he has these these
are toys like he has like live-action
toys and he gets to show them off he's
uh he's also i think the first guest who
has
been open about the fact that their
legacy is very important to them
and that he wants to be talked about how
he
wants his daughter to he wants to make
sure that she has all his
movies and is aware of
um
and he's also very aware of
what people think of him yeah i don't
think there's anything wrong with caring
about your legacy most of the guests i
most of the guests we've had say a
version of oh i don't care about that
what's you know what happens to me you
die or how how i'm remembered who gives
a [ __ ] and there's something cool about
that and i and i
i respect that answer but i also kind of
respect
people saying no i i want my work to
live on and i the things i've done in
this life i want people to watch my
movies it i'm not saying it's a negative
thing but
i just think it's interesting that he's
the first to be more honest person who
has really
said that you know
he said he wants his epitaph to say he
made clerks remember
right but is that just for the joke or
like because then you think so because
it
he he said enough of those that suggest
that it's not a joke well he does he's
very aware now of his legacy i mean
jane's silent bob reboot this new movie
he's made that he's promoting is all
about his legacy all of the characters
in it are his universe that he's created
he's created this he calls it the view
askew
escuve universe i just hope he doesn't
focus too much on on the criticism
well that's the problem if you're going
to do that and just like to be like [ __ ]
it i'm not careful people think and he
does care i know it's interesting
should we read a letter yeah crystal r
do you want to read it no you read
the subject is how i [ __ ] it and pull it
i love that
people are saying that uh people one
person
dear justin and christian hey guys i
heard justin mentioned life is short on
armchair expert about a month ago now
i'm hooked i especially enjoy the
segments before and after the interviews
when the two of you are just chopping it
up about random things i've never heard
that expression chopping it up i hope
it's a good thing
it's true i'm like thank you
knowing things yeah it means you like
mangle things
you guys make me laugh out loud in my
car by myself on a weekly basis thank
you for that
thank you crystal
the way i like to quote cockett and pull
it in life is by teaching people the
things i'm passionate about i've
recently started teaching a kids cooking
class that's cool so that's a good way
to start
sorry
out here in kenosha wisconsin oh kenosha
with my nine-year-old son quentin we've
created a series of classes full of
delicious and healthy recipes and it's
been a lot of fun so far that is cool
our goal is to provide a mindful
learning environment and to encourage
kids to eat healthier while teaching
them basic cooking skills they can carry
with them throughout life because
life is short smiley face on a side note
i was listening to the end of the neil
degrasse tyson episode when you guys
were debating about the grass oh why do
i keep saying that degrassi high tigra
[Music]
he was degraded
um
uh when you guys were debating about
debating about cilia
i also used to teach anatomy and uh
physiology and i can tell you
justin was right no
[ __ ]
there are cilia in your nasal cavities
another smiley face
i'm also smiling can't wait to hear
what's next uh
crystal and and her emoji is a kissing
cat which i don't see a lot i'm kissing
yet that's really cool and uh we should
say her thing is um it's called in the
kitchen with crystal and quentin that's
really cool uh sunday november 17th
at 12 if you want to go if you're in the
kenosha area
get on over that's such a cool idea that
is cool but
i'm not convinced crystal's right about
this a doctor friend of mine after that
episode came out
sent me a link
to uh celia you get it you have smart
friends
and it is a cellular thing
oh yeah it is i by the way i by the way
by the way i googled it um and it is but
it's also
found
on a molecular level uh in in the nasal
membranes okay so we're both right but i
was wrong i was wrong because i did
think in in your defense and in crystals
non-defense i thought it was the hairs
in your what are those calls just nasal
hairs nose hair nose hair boring gross
well thanks crystal and thanks for
everyone who uh wrote in and who
continues to write in and if you have
anything you'd like to share you can
reach us at life is short at
wondering.com
and uh thank you thanks so much to kevin
uh and this was really fun to talk to
him so thanks for listening
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
so this has been life is short i am one
of your shorties
you're not a shorty you're not on
facebook i know but i'm in spirit i'm a
shorty all right i'm an actual shortie
uh-huh and producer christian long um
our other producer who i don't know if
she's as shorty as megan monaco our
senior producer is michelle miche lans
audio engineer is marcelino via vipando
executive produced by marshall louis and
ernan lopez for
wondering
why do you think charlie brown's so put
upon
well here's the thing i used to think it
was because he was bald but i remember
damian pointing out to me that he's not
bald he's got little wispy hairs yeah
but it's like he has one two hairs but
here's the thing even if he was bald
he's totally well adjusted
he like being bald no yeah yeah as a kid
as a but he's drawn like he has alopecia
or something doesn't it but they never
yeah but i don't think he does
oh but but don't you think that's maybe
why he was kicked on
because he has alopecia not alopecia but
he's bald
they never mentioned no one's ever like
hey q-tip no one's ever like
ball
reference is baldy you tip an insult for
bald people
cue ball cue ball
you're just a rapper
uh
no you know what he does
knows me he's kind of a dior yeah he is
but you know what he does he's he screws
things up i guess because like when he
was making his halloween costume he they
were going as ghosts and he had like all
these holes in his and i guess so he
does stuff like that
isn't snoopy always outwitting him like
is he just like yeah well snoopy's
cooler i get that but why do kids care
if he's not great at like but charlie i
think is is so much less offensive than
his sister for one oh my god she's just
like so annoying she's just like an
[ __ ] what's her name
lucy
um sally is just like kind of sweet and
effective yeah lion sucks his thumb
here's a blanket everything but i like
linus
i'd like him but i it still doesn't make
sense that he wouldn't get picked on
more schroeder is always buried in that
piano pink pen stinks
like
of that group charlie is uh he's like
one of the more normal ones
so he makes mistakes sometimes
i know i know
the only thing that i could think of
which they never mentioned so i don't
think it's baldness i think it's just
how he's drawn
boy i'm sure lioness is drawn with like
eight hair and stuff
all the way back and
and uh
who's who's lucy oh peppermint patty
yeah lucy's oh
patty's weird too
she just like follows these little
cigarettes around yeah agrees with
everything she says
yes sir yes she never gets made fun of
they're so mean to charlie brown you
know the advantage that's part of the
strategy is that charlie is the most
normal one but yet he gets picked out
all the time
maybe there's a lot what's the message
uh
any everyone
all kids are [ __ ] and anyone is
subject to ridicule no matter what
it's a weirdness so you think that you
are so don't get down about it yeah even
if your chin up even someone as
innocuous as charlie brown gets [ __ ] on
so don't
don't don't let bullies
you